so welcome everybody for those of you I
don't know
actors of the Center for business in the
environment at Yale and I'm thrilled to
be here talking with Kathy Loftus from
whole foods and we'll have some time for
all of you to speak with Kathy as well
later this is the second in this year's
series of the sustainability leaders
talks Kathy's going to talk to us today
about how Whole Foods weaves its green
mission into everything that it does and
how this has helped to become the
nation's leading green food retailer
Cathy's role at Whole Foods is to
coordinate sustainability programs
including the overall company impact
reporting as well as engineering energy
management maintenance green building
and strategic energy procurement and
she's been doing this for the last six
years she comes to this position with a
BS and mechanical engineering from
Worcester Polytechnic Institute as well
as work as a director of business
development for a start-up energy
technology firm an electric utility
company and eight years at Shaw super
smart Shaw supermarkets as director of
Energy and Environmental Management as
if this wasn't enough she's also
involved in a huge array of activities
in the community and the state
nationally including the energy
efficiency action network of
Massachusetts their utility motivation
working group being an advisor for the
grocery sector of the US Green Building
Council's lead program on our towns
Renewable Energy Commission and share of
a wonderful not-for-profit clean air
cool planet so delighted to have you
with us today Thank You Brad
and you know sort of let's get started
with the question on the poster you know
you all are considered the leading green
grocery retailer in the US what sets you
apart how'd you get there well I have to
say it's our team members and we're so
fortunate because we do attract the best
the brightest the most passionate and
it's goes way back to nineteen eighty
with the first store that opened
everybody who works at whole foods
market becomes part of this family and
really just has this as their DNA and
their ethos and we we don't have a
top-down approach we're very
decentralized kind of tribes if you will
but I found and I'm only I'm new I'm 66
years into this so I'm privileged to
actually go to work for a company that
had the values that I did and that's
really what drew me to it but it's
people like Lee and all of you that are
here today that give me my inspiration I
really think that's what sets us apart
it's it's kind of an inside-out approach
that we have and then maybe outside in
but but everybody's really passionate
and brings some expertise to the table
and their vocal and they do talk about
what is important to them and we all
meet it's very consensus-based we don't
have one department that does
sustainability we don't have one chief
sustainability officer we have people
that work on green mission voluntarily
and we have people that do green mission
as part of every every part of their
their work so we can talk more about
that as we go on but it really is woven
into everything that we do so speaking
of being woven and everything that you
do you know sustainability usually very
much depends upon the business case you
know why is it in the company's best
interest to do so you know how what's
the position that you and your whole
green mission reps and other Whole Foods
employees take in making the business
case and how does that manifest itself
well a lot of times I think it comes
from understanding what the real impacts
are and so it's easy to sort of now to
make a business case around energy and
as we saw today around water there may
be some less tangible ways to to develop
and identify a business case for other
things that we do green mission but I
think the great thing is that if we
start small we usually typically start
the pilot and if one or two stores or
one or two regions adopt something then
it's easy to make that bit that big
sorry bigger business case and spread it
out but but people will come up with
some packaging ideas for example and for
ideas with anything related to what we
do business wise and they will just try
to look for what are some of the impacts
not just economically but socially and
environmentally because we have this
stakeholder approach hopefuls market
uses we live by our core values we have
a declaration of interdependence but we
truly believe in the fully stakeholder
model and by looking at what some of
those impacts might be socially and
environmentally that we can somehow add
to a case you know for us to maintain
our leadership and green mission it's
tough to put a price tag on some of
those kinds of things that we do but if
we feel that we want to have the best
people working at our stores because
there are front people working with
customers and need to be knowledgeable
and educated and passionate about what
they do then we want to maintain our
leadership for those reasons among many
others so can you give an adjust
mentioned the stakeholder approach can
you give an example of that in action
yes absolutely so Lee Kane is here and
he works in local and foraging some of
the things that we do is we'll work with
folks that might know a little bit more
about agricultural things for example I
mean nobody probably knows more about
some of our organics than Errol who's
here and some others but if there's
something that we may not be aware of
and we have a criticism for example from
somebody will you know try to strike a
dialogue with that person and learn and
understand what's at stake and then
invite some programs to happen as a
result of that so many of you may
remember when Michael Pollan wrote The
Omnivore's Dilemma you know there was
some criticism about big organic food
and and we learned from that and we went
out and we developed the local producer
loan program so we work with local
farmers and local producers try to get
small startup companies
out there and available for us and a lot
of that helps us on the supply chain and
also helps environmentally and some
other it obviously it's great business
so it's a good economic model as well so
let me follow up on the local food part
there for a second Yale dining is trying
to source more of its produce vegetables
beats locally but there's all sorts of
problems with both local processing and
local distribution and I know that you
know you can't be on top of everything
that's happening but what's your sense
about you know how that was sort of
limits on the system if you will are
affecting your ability to do more in the
local food area yeah I think I'm
definitely gonna feel this out to
arilinn Lee too but just very briefly I
think there are some opportunities again
to work with local producers and
distribution companies that might be
sort of out of the norm so one of the
things that we try to do is is have we
were all on innovation and creativity so
how can we kind of bring together
different sources than we normally would
have thought of otherwise and lead for
example had a work with someone who came
out of the IT industry who started
working with a co-op and bringing
together a whole lot of different
producers locally and then it would have
a distribution system as a result of
that so I don't know if you want to
expand on that a little bit ly and then
we'll go to Eric doing a microphone yes
we do sorry I think it's coming from
this side
behind you
thank you for that you know it's
interesting on the the Yale dining side
for example and we'll probably hear more
about this as lunch it well hour later
on the panel an effort to bring
institutional buyers together to sort of
pool resources you all as a as a
retailer rather than a wholesaler you
know might be an interesting
collaborator in some of those efforts
tell any how exciting I'm speech so you
know we're talking about innovation and
creativity and you talked a lot about
hiring wonderful people who share your
values and decentralized organization
leaving them free to to do what they
want I assume that's the source of a lot
of innovation and creativity are there
any other steps that the company takes
to try to be as innovative and creative
as possible yes absolutely and you just
touched upon it when you said unlikely
alliances and and things like that we
have limited resources we're a big name
company but we're a small company when
you think about the number of team
members that work maybe in the support
functions so typically what I try to do
is maybe work with other retailers work
with other industries to find out how
they made some inroads looking at not
necessarily even trying to invent the
best next thing for food retail or food
production or any other area of our
business but how can we take existing
technologies and use them differently so
new applications for certain things
similar like the fuel cell or some of
the other technological advances we've
made within the industry we look to the
National Renewable Energy Lab some of
the labs out there I think we need to do
more partnering with academia and we've
done that my alma mater they'll be doing
some studies for us and I did it in a
previous job with another institution on
a marketing study you know would
consumers really drive a little bit
further to go to a green supermarket so
I think it's it's really availing
ourselves of all of the different key
players in our industry and other
industries and government and academia
that you can all collaborate together so
you mentioned the consumer evaluation
and would they
further you talk a little bit about how
you measure or how you get a sense for
what parts of the green mission or the
mission as a whole or future missions
customers are most interested in and how
they value that sure absolutely I think
we tend to do a really good job in our
social media efforts and we've got a lot
of blogging going on and a lot of
Facebook pages for each store tweeting
but we also have on our website a
customer response section so we do see a
lot of customer responses and we
published our first green mission report
this year I just love to talk about
because it isn't truly a corporate
social responsibility report and those
are seemingly a little bit more reactive
where we believe in the conscious
capitalism and conscious business models
where when you think about all of these
things as integrated and woven through
your business practices and you sort of
have that in your DNA it's always going
to be proactive and not reactive but we
never really did a great job of telling
all the stories that we about all the
things that we do so whole planet
foundation for example whole kids
foundation the local producer loan
program animal compassion so many
different things that when we are more
profitable and truly sustainable as a
business we can continue to do those
good things and support those
foundations I think that hearing from
our customers as we did as a result of
this green mission report being
published we were floored we knew before
that our customers were interested
because they would write in and they
would respond to blogs one earth month
we had a live blog live podcast if you
will and we had so many different people
from around the country coming in and
talking about what they would do for
example for natural cleaning products
what they do at home so I think it's
this sharing our customers tend to be
pretty vocal and and they have no
problem telling us when they think you
know we should be doing things
differently or improve things with
respect to energy usage and other things
like that but we know our customers care
about the things that they put into
their mouths and they know that healthy
eating is important for example because
they're visiting our wellness clubs and
they talk about that kind of offer
and you know they want to see BPA
removed from plastics they really
support our eliminating plastic bags at
the check at the checkout so there's
just there's a lot of that that we not
only see in here in the stores directly
but then get for feedback so do you
think about customer feedback and
whatnot do you see large geographic
variations and you know how do you
respond to that are there areas of
commonality as well acquiesce as a
matter of fact um I would definitely say
that on the west coast and east coast
and traditionally this is probably
because maybe there is a little bit more
concentrated University and people
understanding maybe what's at stake
because they're at the end of the
pipeline so to speak for energy and
water and things like that so there's
been a little bit more focused in the
news on environmental impacts and as
Mike mentioned grid instability know the
power outage big statement in that as
well but there's um a little bit maybe
more awareness in certain regions of the
country but we will go and visit with
say the south region which who
traditionally wouldn't those folks might
not have known so much and then after
Hurricane Katrina with the power and all
of the other things p when we go out and
talk in the community we kind of bring
with us what we've experienced in other
areas and start talking about it and now
we're seeing that I think there's you
know more of a movement toward
commonality than just you know it's only
happening in certain areas yeah so that
comparison across areas and you
mentioned also you know earlier dear
decentralized structure I assume best
practices sharing across multiple
locations is a big deal and that's not
easy to do you talk a little bit about
some of the successes you've had and
techniques you've used well for that and
and some of the failures are some of the
areas that are proving to be harder for
you in that regard absolutely and before
I forget I'm actually gonna give a shout
out to Allen from Brighton because right
before our session Allen suggested is
there a way that we can do some some
group discussion so that we can talk
more and share what's going on between
us and the green
in group and we had talked about this in
the past we have what we call whole
foods market University and we've worked
with them an IT to develop a platform
where folks could share energy backing
up tips and best practices but I'm
thinking and I told out on this we
should probably develop some kind of a
linkedin group or something where it's
password-protected it's for this group
but everybody can get online and just
share their tips and share their ideas
pick up the phone obviously too but I
think so that's one great thing and
that's something that we know we need to
improve on what we what we've been able
to do in the past well I think in terms
of sharing best practices and I'll
specifically like in this to
construction and new development and
engineering we may have had a couple of
regions of the country that were a
little bit more interested in building
lead they thought their customers might
recognize that label and enjoy that or
Energy Star equipment things like that
so we worked closely with them developed
some models had some great successes and
brought that to our monthly store
development calls and our two or three
times a year that we meet in person and
brought some of those case studies using
PowerPoint using store tours wherever we
can we will bring the folks to the place
that we're going one thing that I think
we could do better and it's absolutely
not a failure but it's it's room for
improvement we worked with the deal we
we worked with the National Renewable
Energy labs to design a new store that
would hopefully use fifty percent less
energy than what was approved by code at
the time because we had some other
things going on in that store we have
some other environmental challenges with
refrigerant gases we also had that kind
of a balancing effect of using the least
amount of energy that we could but also
trying to be proactive in reducing our
refrigerant charge and trying something
a little different on the
state-of-the-art refrigeration side so
while that uses a little bit more energy
it really helps carbon footprint
greenhouse gas emission footprint when
you reduce your refrigerant charge and
potential leaks so this store north
raleigh north carolina achieved a
forty-one percent
proximately lower energy consumption or
modeled lower energy consumption what we
learned we shared but it was more in
this PowerPoint scenario and it was kind
of getting a adoption from other regions
but not really strongly until we had one
region and we brought Michael and stern
on board and he's a key player there
because people trust him as an
independent expert but we SAT and had a
call with their outside engineers and
went through line by line and really
showed how to make this replicable and
how to adopt this practice and so now
we've got a few stores that will be
designed that way or very similarly so I
think the challenge is not necessarily
standing up and lecturing about what
seemed to work but it's showing
everybody the store it's getting your
rolling your sleeves up and getting
getting looking at the drawings and
getting into the nitty-gritty that helps
you sort of think about social
communication social networking use of
avatars or sort of remote tours and
things like that maybe there's some
that's a great idea is anybody taking
notes we can use that that's a great
idea we'll open it up for questions in a
little while but if people have other
thoughts on ways to address some of the
challenges I'm sure that would be a
great part of today's conversation but
speaking of challenges you know as you
look forward both on the sort of
sustainability side as well as on the
economic and environmental parts more
directly what are the big challenges
that you all are facing and how are you
thinking about addressing them I think
we all know some of the major challenges
and agriculturally I mean we're talking
about a loss of arable soil and erosion
of some of that and the water impacts
hugely concerned about the use of
pesticides and fungicides and herbicides
and how that's impacting our food supply
and just agriculture I guess in general
and health impacts so some of those
challenges are we we don't want to
preach to our customers
we want to sort of lead by example and
show the results of living a healthy
lifestyle and choosing certain products
over others but but a challenge is is
somebody went in the bottled water you
know can we just take those all off of
our shelves right now not really because
our customers want those but the
challenge is how do we educate while not
you know kind of lecturing and also
maybe providing as much information as
we can I think it's all about
transparency and we talked about the
nutrition labels on products maybe we
need a little bit more information about
other aspects of how things are grown
and that's a challenge because you know
folks are in the grocery store to pick
up their food and other products and
there's not a lot of mindshare going on
about other things in the store so
that's what we need to use the social
media as you suggested and maybe the
gathering spaces in the stores that's
one nice thing that we have for our
customers so you know maybe there's some
education points and some some ways to
use the stores that way too so you
mentioned quite a range of scales and
time you know from loss of arable land
to nutrition labeling and whatnot I'm
assuming that most of the work that you
all do is much more directed to so how
do we relate to customers today or next
week or something like that arable land
loss or you know where's the food going
to come from or will there be water for
the food it's obviously a much longer
term question how does that come into
your how does that sort of translate
into your business case and your
business activity it's a great question
and we're kind of wrestling with that a
little bit right now and I will speak to
that in a minute too but one of the
things that we do try to do again is
collaborate and be have our finger on
the pulse of everything related to what
we do out there and so we will hear for
example pilot programs going on with
maybe other institutions or other
industries like us we've had a resolve
come to us there a sort of quasi public
agency on the mediation side almost but
there are ways that we might be able to
get involved that can help we don't have
to spend at
of time because we don't have all those
resources but we can get involved
understand what they're doing making
sure that it aligns with us and then
help advocate what we learn out to our
customers so there are some things that
we we try to get involved in that aren't
you know full-time efforts if you will
but really we need to be involved and to
be a part of that message we also
support the expo east and west and we
bring together suppliers for packaging
reduction and new packaging ideas and
things like that but Errol I don't know
if you want to talk a little bit more
about that now or there's some of the
things that we might be doing that are
kind of on the side if you will with
these up to you can you just wait for
quick sec I'm sorry about that all the
sustainability efforts on a procurement
side are front and center for us it's
what we do so we are to our customers by
and anytime we do anything that you know
sort of speaks our customers values our
sales are better it's really part of our
DNA it's it's kind of why I know I work
at whole foods market I wouldn't if it
weren't like that and you know just a
couple examples is that we sell a
billion and a half dollars worth of
organic foods just in grocery the center
store so its bigger than a lot of
retailers overall you know we're the
world's I'm sorry Marika's largest
non-gmo verified retail we have over
5,000 items that are 99.1 percent free
of GMOs we sell more fair trade products
so these are things that are core to our
business model and when we do them well
we do we do well so I can get we can get
more to it later absolutely thank you
that's great one of the sort of geeky
questions that comes up around that is
you know is big organic and oxymoron can
you have a continuation of the highly
energy intensive you know highly land
intensive somewhat vulnerable cropping
system and where does more resilient
local food systems fit you know we
talked touched on this a little bit
earlier but do you see that as an
shoe for you all down the road you know
even maybe shifting a significant part
to the locally produced yes absolutely I
think that we and we can liken it to
energy too but significant through the
local producer loan program and other
support mechanisms for local farming and
just the education that we provide out
there we do see a lot moving toward
local I don't have the statistics and
can't tell you exactly how we might make
some of those switches there are still
some efficiencies for certain ways you
know to be centralized but I think when
we look at energy it's very similar you
know we're trying to bring more and more
on site or local and not necessarily
using some of the centralized resource
models out there so it's like everything
almost we're going to have to have a
balanced portfolio of all of that and
really start to and just learn and
understand more of all of the impacts as
we go so that we make the right choices
and the percent local and present
centralized speaking of portfolio you've
had quite a varied career so far
mechanical engineering energy now food
you know can you talk a little bit about
that path and for people who want to
work in sustainability or particularly
sustainable food systems and how you
might go about advising them or
suggesting yeah and it is a very
interesting and strange journey that
I've had I wanted to be an English
teacher and my parents especially that
you'll never get a job this is back when
you know they weren't hiring teachers
and for whatever reason I was blessed
with kind of a balanced left brain right
brain I'm not saying it was excellent in
both but but as a balance so I thought
okay well what do I have four choices in
the math and sciences how about
engineering you know people said
engineering is a great industry to get
into you'll definitely find a job when
you graduate well the only jobs
available at that time we're really in
the defense industry and I didn't want
to build bombs but I found a small you
know mechanical electrical plumbing
consult
firm that was hiring so I figured why
not and just another side to as much as
I wanted to be an English teacher every
one of my family is well a lot of people
in my family all the women anyway our
nurses and I was the only one only
female that could not stand the sight of
blood or want to do anything with
respect to medical so I remember
thinking oh aha if I become an engineer
I can design prosthetics and then I'm
sort of doing good I'm not going to cure
cancer but I can do something good well
I quickly got into electrical
engineering and biomedical engineering
and thought oh this is much harder than
I thought it was going to be so I
switched to mechanical much more for me
anyway easily understood it's very
visible but again coming out of college
without many prospects and finding this
small mechanical electrical plumbing
company and getting involved in working
with them and seeing what was going on
with the building industry I remember
hanging in there for about a year year
and a half and I thought I can't do this
we're doing such a disservice I mean
this is back before CAD and back before
computers we were hand drafting systems
and we were in the bottom of the talk
about trickle down here so the developer
building owner architect by the time it
gets to the MEP the margins they're
making very little money everything was
cut and paste from this project you know
just use this design and add a safety
factor to everything so again like I
said after about a year this I thought I
just can't do this anymore we're
spending we're going to cause the tenant
to spend way too much money they're
going to be using way more electricity
or gas than they need to and I wasn't
happy so I went to talk to one architect
and one development company and I said
how interested would you be in looking
at a matrix of different options that
take lifecycle costs into consideration
and believe it or not they were really
interested in all over it and they
didn't always pick the you know the best
life cycle cost option but they weren't
only thinking cheap cheap cheap from
that on out they were thinking of some
of the other impacts and this is post
energy crisis of the 70s but this is pre
you know some of the market manipulation
then went on with Enron and some of the
other energy major problems pricing
after Hurricane Katrina so
I consider that a huge coup and it was a
great win and then right after that
there was an energy engineering position
that opened up and I went to work for
the small company in Boston where I
learned from there to VPS who were
amazing because they basically gave me
enough rope but they said you know we'll
be here if you need anything but you're
going to be the front person working
with the mass Rhode Island eeps a lot of
the big utility companies and small not
small small the big manufacturers so I
worked for New England Medical Center
designing a new heating and air
conditioning system for them but all
kinds of exposure and in great learning
and from there went to the electric
utility company where I designed and
developed their conservation and load
management programs for all of their
commercial industrial customers but when
I say I I mean me and a whole lot of
other people because even though I have
this balance of left brain right brain
and I've had a good foundation in my
education and some great people that
have taught me I don't know at you know
I know this much i align myself myself
with the experts because i just know
that there's there's so much more to be
gained by collaborating and always
finding the yin to your yang another
thing I know about myself so I'd like to
think big and I like to get things done
but I don't necessarily like the minutia
and the details and so if you can find
somebody who likes that part of it who
might not be as much of a talker then
you know those those things will yin and
yang out but so I went working for the
electric utility company was again a
great a great background because I
learned was very big business systemic
how things were working i also started
to understand what was going on in the
resource planning side of energy and we
were learning about you know acid rain
and even though i I'm morphed from my
role in The Electric Company to
designing and implementing conservation
management programs to being a key
account person because the electric
utility industry was deregulated they
wanted six people to manage the biggest
accounts for this utility and because I
was the only mechanical engineer they
put me in fire food they said anything
that has refriger
compressors mechanical you're going to
handle okay but what I learned is these
businesses wanted to share what some of
their challenges were and how could we
make them more profitable how could we
understand their load how could we help
them benchmark against each other in
other industries and I quickly you know
lots of great information load
information used all of that to help
these customers one of my customers with
shaw's supermarkets they were needing an
energy and regulatory affairs person so
I applied for the job and I got that job
that's where I met Mike so I took my
electric utility background and said you
know what we're never going to know how
a stores using energy but the whole
house utility bill that comes 30 days
later we need to kind of be more
forensic and we need to get in there do
some submetering and really understand
how and when we're using energy also the
stores don't want to see the maintenance
folks it's unfortunate but they think
it's going to cost them money so they
say you know what just if I said to the
maintenance person for a few stores
we're using one percent more energy can
you go figure out what it is they would
laugh me you know out of the room so
Mike and I and a few others again this
whole collaboration approach we
brainstormed with our refrigeration
people our electrical people from
outside vendors the utilities and we
said if we if we implement this system
we didn't have a budget for it at the
time what do we think we can gain from
it and how can we influence you know
people out there to help us with it so
we show them the business case we were
going to spend two million dollars we
were going to hopefully save a million
we're going to get all of our stores
equipped with this monitoring system
with exception based reporting for a
holistic feedback loop and we did some
control groups and pilots along the way
but we actually were able to get a
couple of utilities to pay one hundred
percent for the system so our two
million dollar investment with a 1
million dollar savings quickly became
you know much lower investment much
higher return on investment so so we got
this program in place and Mike and I
started looking at well you know the
manufacturer of this refrigerated case
recommends that we operated at this you
know these conditions
or some other way of looking at lighting
for example do we really need to do that
or can we test something some of our
HVAC systems how can we operate them
more efficiently so we use this system
to kind of push the boundaries measure
the savings and start to do things in
the industry that were unheard of before
again using existing technology but just
different applications of it and that
when I went to work more when i was at
shaws and I sort of took over from my
boss on food marketing institute's
energy and Technical Services Committee
we brought all kinds of industry experts
together and once a year we had a big
energy and technical services meeting
and we would share things and because we
had this sub metering program and
because we were able to prove to the
utilities what we had for load and when
we had the Yankee nuclear systems go
down the Connecticut Yankee systems go
down on if you remember that but back in
the 90s they were looking for ways new
dirty sources of cheap peak power that
they gave jet engines basically to
inject into the grid or customers like
us to shed load so we had the systems we
shed the load you know benefited greatly
economically from those and were able to
share that out to the industry so that
when there was that massive gas pipeline
we don't know exactly what happened but
you know Enron was around at the time
and gas prices went up here and there
was blackouts out in California because
they had heard what we did at shaws they
all started doing that and eventually
demand response was born so now there
are some programs out there that other
industries are taking advantage up to in
either building on-site generation
that's a way to be available to the
utilities or just shedding load and we
you know we talked about a whole lot of
things like that moving forward and so
working for Shaw's was great Shah's got
bought by a bigger company and this
bigger company at the time thought they
could handle everything from Idaho which
is where they were based so they let me
go in my way and it was probably good
timing because I had been there for
eight years and I think I was at this
point in my life where I needed to try
something new I
never sold before never done business
development but this small startup
company in the demand response industry
as it happens asked me to come join
their team so I worked with them for a
couple of years and again got probably
the background I needed to move to whole
foods market because I was selling
directly as a result and I had never
sold before and coming to whole foods
when the position opened up at Whole
Foods I've been watching them since my
days of chaws wanting to work for this
company because it was such an
incredible company again my values
aligned with them after all my
experiences with big corporate greed and
Enron and the debacle there and
everything else I thought I am so
excited to go to work for a company like
Whole Foods and when I got there I
quickly realized I'm one person and
we're so decentralized I can't get
although my ideas might sound good and
they might be something that we should
be doing I can't get that done you know
necessarily easily that's where I think
having the sales background helped so
consultative selling aligning my cells
with other myself with other experts and
champions I think helped me get a lot of
what we see today our stores and this 10
million dollar capital budget that's
providing us hopefully 25% energy
reduction by 2015 which not only results
in hundreds of millions of
kilowatt-hours that don't get used it
hopefully helps put off building major
power plants and it helps us be much
more profitable so that again
holistically we can come back to
supporting a whole planet foundation
supporting all the other foundations
that we have out there and being a
viable member of the community so you've
got selling more stuff we got building
your brand reducing your costs all
through sustainability not a bad story
we have some time for questions if folks
have if the mics could be available and
if folks could speak only when they have
a mic and quickly state their name and
their affiliation so I've got a question
hi I'm Nick from the woburn store
one quick thing I wanted to interject
with about the freedom comment of
innovation one of the reasons we are so
viable is because we have a culture of
empowerment at Whole Foods and that's
really great and on a more of an
internal matter about communication
getting a linkedin thing we have
sharepoint and that is a really
excellent tool and we could just use
that one more instead of developing a
new one I'm all for that but excellent
no that's a great point and i forgot
about sharepoint so thank you for thank
you for saying that and with just so
you're aware I wrote myself a note to
follow up on it with the experts because
I'm not the expert in that area but
you're absolutely right it's using
grapevine and our existing communication
maybe just tweaking it for this group
thank you coming here be with Whole
Foods and back to your question earlier
Brad about how do we distill best
practices throughout the company I just
want to say that there's one aspect of
our company that most people from the
outside don't really understand or
appreciate and that's we're ferociously
competitive if you think we're
competitive with trader joe's you should
see what we do internally and so you
know these ideas that come along you
know we usually want to pick one store
one region to try new new technology new
practices whatever it happens to be as
soon as that look like looks like it's
going to work or it looks like it's
going to get some good media attention
the operations people are falling all
over each other to be the next to do it
so it happens pretty much you know and
Kim might want to add to this as one of
our operations people but our stores
compete with each other our departments
compete against each other our region's
compete against each other I mean it's
really a phenomenal part of our culture
that again most people from the outside
wouldn't really understand her
necessarily see on a day-to-day basis
Kim do you want to say anything kash ask
you if I can follow up question
sometimes competition gets in the way of
sharing how do you all have the two we
that's an excellent question and so the
first part of it is whoever it is wants
to be first to
do it we were the first in Glastonbury
Connecticut to put a fuel cell into our
store first supermarket in the world
Kathy correct to have a fuel cell and so
you know Glastonbury was very happy to
be the first to do that and then quickly
share that you know that win with the
rest of the stores and with the rest of
the region so that's kind of you know we
always want to be first when we were
talking to the UTC who made the fuel
cell we said you know the only thing we
want you to understand is we want to be
the first supermarket to have a fuel
cell and then after that we want
everybody to have it but we want to be
first yeah no you're absolutely right
over here Matt from White Plains I just
wanted to share some ideas and best
practices when I was working for a
guitar center we had a basically a
social network called gain central where
employees could upload their songs and
talk about you know whatever they want
to talk about so I thought that was
interesting and related to the idea I
mean imagine sharepoint which is great
but if we could add a social media
aspect to that where you know and I go
on my computer and I can login at home
check out facebook check on Whole Foods
social media you know i'll definitely be
more in the network if if we could
access it from home and also you
mentioned educating without preaching i
think a best practice we have in white
plains is every few weeks we'll show a
movie an educational documentary like
vanishing of the bees or fat sick and
nearly dead some of those great
documentaries that you know are right in
line with with our core values thank you
thank you that's great
hi I'm drove from Paramus and I had a
question about the comment that when
customer values are addressed in sales
are better and that this pertains to we
can we see the green machine report
customer report that had such positive
feedback for us is that on SharePoint or
and the reason why I asked that because
sometimes decisions in a department may
be made based on cost immediate cost and
not looking at the long-range picture
yeah for instance I asked a question
last week why we're using certain types
of containers instead of that the
containers that are a better for the
environment and we're using the old
brown continuously saying they said well
it's basically a cost issue yep and
there's still we know that there's still
a little way to go in some areas with
sharing best practices and sharing
information and looking at long-term
lifecycle costs but you know I think to
your first question the green mission
report is on the whole foods market
website but I believe there's also a
location on the green mission SharePoint
but we can get you that after the after
the meeting i'm sure we'll have some
notes and we'll have a way to let
everybody know what we're talking about
and where it is and with respect to some
of those you know sort of container and
other even small where equipment things
like that what we're doing is we're now
centrally working with the regional
equipment buyers and some of the
regional green mission specialists to to
share this information on okay this
might cost a little bit more but here
are the longer-term benefits and getting
more specifications if you will that
would be not standards but again getting
the information out so that so that we
are making those decisions appropriately
and the I don't know if you want to add
to that at all okay yeah but that's
basically if you have time for one more
in the back there me or do you have a om
sorry yep John hi my name is John warco
I'm a professor of environmental health
and politics here and this this term
I've launched a new graduate research
seminar on the future of food
and one of the recurring questions that
comes up in the seminar is how to deal
with the complexity of all the
environmental and energy and health
issues that surround foods how to deal
with the complexity in a way that could
really educate and empower consumers to
practice more responsible purchasing so
I'm wondering your thoughts about this
and you know the topics that come up are
the pesticides but also plastics energy
questions after Fukushima radionuclides
and fish so that there are there are
many different concerns and challenges
that that my students are worried about
and I imagine most other people are that
many people feel like they need to have
a really good night's sleep before they
walk into a supermarket and and and face
the the different claims that are being
made and and nobody really knows which
claim to believe so I'm wondering what
you think the the role or the
responsibility of a corporation like
yours might be to try to help educate
the consumer and I'm especially
interested as are some of my students in
the potential for scanning technology to
possibly be a vehicle to to cut through
some of the the highly complex knowledge
did you just say scanning scanning
technology well here's where again I'll
probably have a limited response and
open it up to some of my team members
first of all I think we are absolutely
as concerned and want to be considerate
about how we educate our customers we
are doing some of that now through the
wellness clubs in some of the stores and
through a lot of even if we don't have a
wellness club in the store we have a
healthy eating section and we typically
will have either a chef or folks
available to talk to our customers about
what they're eating as you mentioned i
know there's in some of the other stores
too we might have a showing of
documentaries or something that's a
little bit third party so it's not kind
of just a whole foods branded education
piece if you will but i think we we do
want to collaborate
more with academia and government where
we can to make sure that this is all
happening holistically again there
aren't silos because it's difficult
right now there's a lot of boundaries
around specific areas of all those
things that you mentioned and I think we
need to start figuring out how to
integrate it all maybe it's things that
we do in business schools and things
that we do in graduate studies too but
you know I hear from people that oh you
know I live in the city and I'm a
musician and I don't have enough money
to spend on organic food for example and
that's when you know we'll try to say
okay but what are you spending on advil
or what are you spending on health care
because you know you're not active and
you're not yours to try to broaden their
thinking that it isn't just this one
cost so I think there's more of that
that needs to get done too similarly
with packaging and bolt versus both and
a whole lot of other areas like that
that I think we need to broaden out but
I don't know if Lee or aryl want to add
to that we're going to need to wrap soon
so if you do please short I was just
going to say we've got a whole a seminar
where we can cover all those topics so
uh that's the afternoon excellent
perfect great great segue then like I
apologize that I'm going to have to cut
the questions off because we have a
panel coming up in 10 minutes that will
continue the conversation on a lot of
these topics I want to thank the GE
foundation for their support for the
sustainability leaders lecture series
also want to thank our partners at the
Yale Office of Sustainability I'll
sustainable food program and i have to
say just personally having been involved
in a lot of these business programs I'm
not sure I've ever seen one where we've
had such a combination of people from
the company and people from Yale
engaging in conversation together and so
I think that's been tremendously
valuable and i look forward to other
opportunities to do that in the future
and I'd asked you all to join me in
thanking Cathy very much for her okay
ok